[Music]
Here I am 49 I've talked a lot of people
do a lot of things for free yes
for years yes I don't feel business as a
health yep new website yep Brandon in
our Travel Club and everything and in my
wife because she's didn't know who you
were yep
and she goes so what are you gonna ask
him I said I don't know and she's like
why don't you ask him how long how long
do you have to do it for free no it says
listen like listen I'll be honest with
you I'm almost sure about it as well
because it is 100% my biggest
vulnerability to it might be at
different scales people may look at like
all this but I've left so much on the
table right like I owe nothing of why my
brain
AJ 150 percent of this when I had all
the leverage like like I've left so much
and my great fear is resentment okay and
that's what I keep telling her is that
here's the thing I don't look back it's
good and then at some point down the
road success meets opportunity
right it's one of those things where I
have planned we even put like this
moment I've shot hundreds of blocks
hundreds of times
built all these things and it's like you
don't know when that one time that one
cuz I don't think cuz I don't think it's
one time to be frank right my intuition
is it's getting into the pattern of
asking for what you're looking for but
being okay with not getting it and and
will you give right giving means you
have no expectation on the other side
manipulating is when you give with the
thought you're gonna get and what people
that love people that give don't
understand is it's our natural DNA the
end well you but winning comes in a lot
of shapes and forms I'll be very frank
with you if I do not buy the New York
Jets I would have won because winning
for me is the chase of the New York Jets
I've already won you always say the
journey hundred percent like people
don't want to hear it
I'll get booed when I'm 90 for not doing
it did you care of course not because
that's winning for me and winning you
know spouses especially is a real tricky
one it's of all the ones it's the
trickiest one because they love you the
most
most hide into you so I have a lot of
empathy for the men and women who have a
spouse who's on the Gib train you know
you have to define winning if you've
been giving this whole time with the
hope that some she drops I have a ton of
empathy for that but you have to frame
that in your head well then you've won
but but you have to ask yourself and
it's okay if you've been hoping that it
leads
that's so unbelievably ok just as okay
somebody who always take everything's ok
you first have to ask yourself which one
is it for me I will never let anybody
have leverage on that is my happiness I
get it I get it I I think deciding that
winning is if your hope is that you all
this giving leads to business
opportunities that's great
I believe I wrote a book called Jab Jab
right hook I believe that that's how it
does work but only in the macro I will
never give to her with the expectation
that she delivers for me of something I
need I'll be comfortable to ask I won't
be disappointed if like I've had I've
told some stories unbelievable I've
given ask for something a tenth of it
person didn't deliver but you know look
there's that initial like you know like
talk and then you're like and then just
like I don't have a capability of
dwelling so I think the question becomes
for you what is winning for me no
question I'm about statues and how many
people show up to my people it's very
clear to me and so to me that matters
like I want to stun my grandkids of how
many people who decide to show up like
that will the greatest day of my life
will be the first day I don't see it you
know I know that and so as if you
imagine just giving is that leverage but
if you're looking for some short-term
financial reward that's super acceptable
what you need to make the change up
is being clear about that because the
cliched thing I see in other givers is
they love the altruism that they give
but they have a burning resentment and
anger or fear inside that they're not
getting of course I'll tell you why cuz
you didn't ask for it upfront or set the
framework for the potential of an
upfront which makes sense right right
you see where I'm going
that makes sense because if you didn't
do it now you know you're sandbag and
the person that makes you feel bad as it
should I love that about you on a quick
read what you want to think about is
that is that macro work leading to
opportunity because somebody's word of
mouth or do you set it up in the
beginning be like hey brother I'll give
you one video but then I want you to buy
one video and that's great and would you
like that or no and that's up to you yep
and by the way you've gotten without
even knowing for that giving in many
different ways the question becomes a
what's the difference between you
winning from your eyes versus your
wife's eyes but it starts with you
because your wife is taking pillow talk
and random conversations and making in
her own I know I gotta go right uh you
know what I mean
it's super important and here's the best
part about forty nine you're a [ __ ]
halftime yes and it's really hard to
know that because when you're twenty two
forty nine feels finished but when
you're think about how young we all feel
I wish he knew that we feel the same as
him
how are you chase how are you all right
a couple days ago what 24 doesn't know
is when you're double D H you feel
exactly the same inside exactly the same
you guys feel exactly the [ __ ] same
that's right it's the same [ __ ]
everything
49 years old sometime yeah just gotta
ask upfront
you know what I mean like I'm like hey I
want to sell sneakers I'm like if you
buy and you see how I do it and if you
buy sneakers then I'd like you to buy
them but you don't have to and you're
more than welcome to continue to consume
my content for free in perpetuity and as
a matter of fact I'm so hungry to sell
them I'm gonna give you a chance to get
what you really want which is access
[Music]